the movie that's going head-to-head with
Harry Potter this weekend has revealed
itself
[Music]
we need the Pooh
right now there are two kinds of people
looking forward to Winnie the Pooh this
weekend really little kids and chicks I
don't know why they just love ticker
they love them now Whitney the Pooh I
can say it's about Winnie the Pooh news
friends but it's ultimately about
Christopher Robin's imagination since
that's where it takes place
that's right among Christopher Robin's
imagination he has imagined the most
depressing jackass on earth and a
drug-addict bear and we need the Pooh is
absolutely a drug addict you cannot deny
that the entire time he's like I love er
what I love about ER is that everyone
knows in ER you know you know that
person where you like dude that guy's a
or that's for the plot of this movie I
don't know it's really simple movie
Winnie the Pooh is looking for honey II
or loses his tail it's a really safe
movie for kids it's almost like Disney
was like all right we recognize that
movies and shows and cartoons these days
are turning kids into
let's face it there are a lot of
kids in the world I said
they're like okay we're gonna go back to
our sixties roots to give the kids a
movie where parents can be like all
right I feel safe showing my kid this
most cartoons and animations these days
have those innuendos the only parents
get you no kid it'll go over kids heads
but parents are like I get that that's
awesome not wanting to prove it doesn't
get more rated G than wanting the poo
now I'd like to say that a nostalgic
part of me was glad to see Winnie the
Pooh back on the screen but I didn't
really grow up on Winnie the Pooh I know
I saw it a few times but it was never
like my cartoon maybe I grew up to be an
because of it all I know is that
if I was gonna relate to one character
in a group it was gonna be one of the
Ninja Turtles yes a lot of kids had
their entertainment with a little bear
looking for honey I needed foot soldiers
and ninjas it is Who I am that being sad
I recognize what Winnie the Pooh is and
it appeals to its demographic really
well if you're in kindergarten or below
you're gonna love Winnie the Pooh let me
rephrase if you know someone who's in
kindergarten or below they're gonna love
one either boo I really doubt those kids
watch my videos if you take them to see
Winnie the Pooh you're gonna chuckle a
few times you're gonna enjoy the fact
that you know this kind of entertainment
still exists you're gonna be playing
Angry Birds who we kiddin I'm probably
gonna get some hate for that but all I'm
saying is that if you're in the double
digit age range it might be a little you
know boring sometimes it's only an hour
long note so it's relatively painless in
fact it could have probably premiered on
TV not against Harry Potter but it's a
great movie for kids so family should go
watch it show your kids what life is
like without Peter Grey
just saying the winnie-the-pooh gangs
probably a better role model kind of so
I will say for what it is it's a good
time no alcohol required that is if your
kid doesn't have a TV I can just see a
little kid with a TV watching this movie
and they'll be like it's been 20 minutes
now I need some action that was me as a
kid so that's why I say this so of the
group which character are you of course
I'm talking about the Ninja Turtles or
you can use a Winnie the Pooh character
you know if you want comment below let
me know what if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]